Imagine this, you're asked to
participate in a panel discussion and
the moderator asks you a question
and all of a sudden
your mind goes blank.
You can't think of the answer. And then
you start to internally panic and you
look out at the audience and you wonder
what they must be thinking about the
fact that you're not saying anything.
Has this ever happened to you?
Or maybe you've never sat on a panel,
but this very idea is one of the reasons
why you don't do that because you panic
about the concept of freezing in front
of a group of people.
It's okay. The first thing to know is
that silence is actually all right.
Because while you may be internally
freaking out
the audience isn't. In fact, some of the
best professionals and the most
impactful thought leaders are the types
of individuals who do take a few moments
before they respond. And they think
through the question and then they
deliver an answer. In this video, I'm
going to give you a couple of mental
frameworks which should help you if you
are ever in the situation of being on a
panel. I promise you by the end of this
video, you will be able to participate
confidently in any panel discussion you
are invited to. If you were asked to be
on a panel discussion, there is a
four-letter acronym that I want you to
remember. PREP. P R E P. This stands for
point reason, example, and then point.
To give you an example of this, if I
were asked a question about what makes a
great office culture
my response could be
I think that a great office culture is
shaped by intentional leadership. And
the reason for that is that culture goes
beyond simply a motto that's written on
a poster that hangs on the wall. It is
shaped by the daily activities that the
leader sets forth. As an example, I have
the chance to work with some great
RE/MAX broker owners throughout Western
Canada and some of these individuals are
running weekly meetings. They offer
additional training. They have social
events on Friday afternoons and every
one of those agents wants to come into
the office and be part of that cuz they
get a certain energy being part of that
culture. And the reason for this is that
the leaders are intentional. They make a
purpose of showcasing great leadership
and great office culture. That was my
response. And if we break down the
different segments, I started off with
the P, the point, and that is office
culture is shaped by intentional
leadership. Then the reason for that is
that it goes beyond a motto written on a
poster and it has to do with the
examples set by the leaders on a daily
basis. And then I gave an example from
my own personal career working with
RE/MAX Canada and having the opportunity
to work with a lot of broker owners and
see what great leadership looks like and
pointing out some of the things they do
well, which brought me back to that
original point that it's all about
intentional leadership. So if you can
remember that PREP acronym, that is
going to help give you a framework so
that any question you get, you're able
to dive in to details. Not just give a
direct answer, but give an example.
>> [snorts]
>> And why is an example important? We as
humans, we gravitate towards stories or
actual
tangible things that we can think of
which can help us envision how we can
apply it to our own lives. So it's not
enough to just give your answer with the
reason why you're giving your answer.
Really aim to find a real-life example
that you can implement as part of your
response. There is a mental framework
that is going to help you if you were
ever asked to be part of a panel
conversation or this could even work if
you're invited to be on a podcast,
especially if you're given a question
that is very difficult or something that
even feels a little bit like a trap.
Like whatever answer you provide might
not put you in the best light. What you
want to remember is acknowledge,
transition, and deliver.
As an example, pretend you are a
financial advisor and you are asked,
"How do you think current government
economic policies are impacting
investors?"
That question might seem a little bit
like a trap in that you don't want to go
too far maybe injecting your own
political beliefs knowing that your
audience is going to have a wide range
of different independent thoughts on how
the government is handling the current
economic climate.
You can still answer and provide value
in a way that sets you up for success.
How you do this using acknowledge,
transition, deliver is you could respond
by saying
"There are certainly a lot of opinions
on how the government is handling this
economic situation. What I like to focus
on are strategies that are going to work
under any form of government because
sure, this government is in power right
now, but that could change at the next
election. So what I like to advise my
clients on are things like
diversification,
risk management, long-term strategy and
investments that have a track record of
proven success. And that way, the best
investors aren't getting caught up on
the short-term policies. They're looking
at it with a much longer lens and I
think that this is a strategy that many
people could deploy. There you go.
You've still provided value. You've
still answered the question, but you
didn't get trapped in injecting your own
opinion on how the current government is
handling the situation. So this is one
way. I just used the government example
as one example. Maybe you're somebody
who does want to answer that directly
and all the power to you, that's fine.
But if you ever get in a situation where
you want to be a bit careful with how
you answer, you want to remember
acknowledge, deliver, and transition.
One thing that very few people think
about when they're participating on a
panel is what they're doing when they
are not being asked a question. Cuz if
you're part of a panel, there's at least
going to be one other participant or
panelist. There might even be multiple
panelists and the amount of speaking
time you have may only be 20 or 33%
of that entire session.
What you're doing when you're not
answering a question is important and
can actually impact how people perceive
you in terms of an expert on stage. Some
suggestions are first and foremost, of
course, to be paying attention to every
question that's asked even if it's not
asked of you directly because sometimes
moderators will suddenly add in, "Wait,
what do you think about what Suzy just
answered?"
And if I'm all of a sudden caught off
guard and I wasn't listening carefully
to Suzy's answer that's not going to
look great. Also, there may be
opportunities for you to jump in. If
Suzy touched on something that maybe you
have a little bit of a different
viewpoint on or something you want to
double down and agree on with what Suzy
said you can always request to jump in
with the moderator or add an additional
thought and now you're adding even more
value to the panel. Beyond this, you
want to ensure that you have eye contact
with the moderator. When you're speaking
to the audience, have that eye contact
and try to keep a smile on your face. A
lot of people don't realize, but they're
very serious when they're on panels and
they just have this grumpy resting face
about them.
But still smile. Still make people feel
like it's enjoyable session. You can
still add humor. You can do all of the
things that you would do in a regular
speech and inject those things as part
of the panel discussion. But it's
important to remember that even when
you're not answering the question,
everyone is still looking your way and
so you want to be paying attention,
focused throughout the entire session. I
hope these tips on mental frameworks and
concepts of how to handle a panel
conversation have been beneficial to
you. If they have, please consider
subscribing to my channel and check out
this deeper dive video which goes
further in depth of how you can be a
great panelist.